>> Pete: WELCOME BACK, A
SIMPLE BUT VERY CRITICAL CHANGE
IN OUR MILITARY POLICY IS SAVING
AMERICAN LIVES ON THE
PRECIOUS LIVES ON AUGUST 6TH
2011 WHEN THE CHOPPER EXTORTION
17 WAS SHOT DOWN -- KILLING ALL
38 ABOARD.
IT WAS THE SINGLE LARGEST LOSS
OF AMERICAN LIFE IN THE HISTORY
MEMBER AARON VAUGHN AND HIS
PARENTS KAREN AND BILLY BELIEVE
THE MILITARY'S RESTRICTIVE RULES
OF ENGAGEMENT UNDER
PRESIDENT OBAMA CONTRIBUTED TO
RULES CHANGE AND OTHER
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS KNOWN THAT
THEY BELIEVE THOSE CHANGES ARE
SAVING LIVES.
BILLY VAUGHN JOINS US NOW.
BILLY, THE STORY OF YOUR SON,
AMERICAN WARRIOR FOUGHT FOR OUR
COUNTRY AND FROM THE VERY
BEGINNING YOU AND KAREN HAVE
BEEN DEDICATED TO MAKING SURE
WHAT HAPPENED THERE AND THAT
VALLEY AND AFGHANISTAN DOESN'T
HAPPEN AGAIN.
ENGAGEMENT THAN TO UNLEASHING
OUR MILITARY?
>> FIRST OF ALL, THANK YOU FOR
HAVING ME TONIGHT.
ABSOLUTELY AFTER AARON WAS
KILLED AND KAREN AND I BEGAN TO
WE ARE NOT MILITARY EXPERTS.
WHERE PARENTS WHO LOVE OUR SON
AND OF OUR COUNTRY AND OUR
MILITARY.
AND AFTER WE BEGAN TO FIND OUT
THINGS THAT SHOULD HAVE HAPPENED
THAT DIDN'T HAPPEN, WE DO
EVEN JUST ONE OF THEM HADN'T
HAPPENED AARON AND THOSE MEN MAY
HAVE BEEN ALIVE TODAY.
PRESIDENT TRUMP PROMISED HE
WOULD CHANGE THE RULES OF
ENGAGEMENT.
AND TALKED ABOUT THE RULES OF
BOTH OF US TALKED ACROSS THE
COUNTRY ABOUT THAT.
WE WERE ABLE TO MEET WITH
10-CANDIDATE TRUMP AND YOU KNOW
THIS, WE GOT THE MOST POWERFUL,
THE MOST EFFICIENT MILITARY THE
WORLD HAS EVER SEEN.
NIGHT IF THEY ARE UNLEASHED TO
DO WHAT THEY ARE TRAINED TO DO
AND UNDER PRESIDENT OBAMA THAT
JUST DIDN'T HAPPEN.
>> Pete: IF THEY ARE ALLOWED.
YOUR CAVEAT IN YOURSELF SAYING
YOU ARE NOT A MILITARY EXPERT.
THAT ALMOST ALLOWS YOU TO BRING
MORE COMMON SENSE TO THE
DISCUSSION AND CERTAINLY
INVESTMENT WITH YOUR SON.
A LOT OF PEOPLE WHO HAVEN'T BEEN
IN THE MILITARY, THEY SAY WHAT
ARE THESE RULES OF ENGAGEMENT,
WHAT ARE THE RATIONALE FOR
PUTTING POLITICAL CONSTRAINTS ON
WARRIORS ON THE BATTLEFIELD AS
OPPOSED TO UNLEASHING THEM,
ESPECIALLY AGAINST A THREAT LIKE
ISIS MARK >> LET ME GIVE YOU A
FOR INSTANCE.
ON THE NIGHT THAT AARON WAS
KILLED, THERE WAS NOTHING FIRED
BEFORE THE HELICOPTER WENT IN.
THAT'S WHEN YOU DON'T HAVE TO BE
A MILITARY EXPERT -- YES, SIR, .
THAT WASN'T JUST AN ISOLATED
INCIDENT.
THE HELICOPTER PILOTS, WHEN THEY
WERE GIVING TESTIMONY, BOTH OF
THEM, ONE OF THEM SAID THERE'S A
ONE IN A MILLION CHANCE WE CAN
GET THAT FIRE APPROVE.
AT THE OTHER ONE SAID WE NEVER
ASKED FOR IT BECAUSE IT'S NEVER
APPROVED ANYMORE.
IN TWO DIFFERENT TESTIMONIES AT
TWO DIFFERENT TIMES.
THAT COULD HAVE SAVED THEM LAST
NIGHT.
ON THE GROUND WAS NOT ALLOWED TO
ENGAGE THOSE ENEMY COMBATANTS
WITH WEAPONS AND IT'S VERY
LIKELY THAT ONE OF THOSE ENEMY
COMBATANTS TOOK THE CHOPPER DOWN
THAT NIGHT.
PRESIDENT TRUMP IN AUGUST SAID
THE GROUND, TO THOSE PEOPLE AND
UNDER PRESIDENT OBAMA, A LOT OF
A LOT OF THAT AUTHORITY, AS YOU
MADE AN EARLIER COMMENT TONIGHT,
WAS BEING DONE BY PEOPLE BACK IN
WASHINGTON, D.C., INSIDE THE
WHITE HOUSE WHO HAD NEVER
SEEN -- WHO HAD NEVER BEEN IN
THE BATTLEFIELD AT NIGHT WITH
THEIR BODIES WITH BULLETS
WHIZZING BY THEIR HEADS.
>> Pete: THAT MAKES ALL THE
THANK YOU FOR EVERYTHING YOU'VE
FIGHTERS IN THE LAST YEAR AND A